attendez mais ça fait 30 ans que ça
existe dans le sport et ça n'est que
depuis très récemment qu'on en parle
quand on a avec roselyne bachelot à
l'époque qui était ministre des sports
réalisé l'enquète qui a donné lieu aux
rapports ministériels
c'était isabelle demongeot qui venait de
consolât qui venait de prendre la parole
et
régis de camaret c'est l affaire de
camaret c'est à l'époque avec les
investigations qu'on a mené on a montré
qu'il y avait en france 10 7% des
sportifs qui déclarait avoir déjà été
confrontés à diverses formes de violence
de violences sexuelles pour un certain
nombre d'entre elles ce sont des
victimes on va dire de prédateurs qui
correspond tout à fait à ce que ce qui
vient d'être dit les cas de d'audrey de
sarah sont similaires dans un certain
nombre de deux points de vue de en tout
cas ce niveau là mais ce qu'on a montré
également c'est comme danser dans la
neige
dans la majorité des cas les sportifs
qui sont victimes de violence sont
victimes d'autres sportifs et ça on en
parle oui c'est la majorité des cas
c'est ce qu'on appelle des violences
horizontale c'est à dire des sportifs
qui s'en prennent à d'autres sportifs
dans des contextes absolument sordide
dans des contextes de bizutage ou ses
défaites des rites initiatiques ou des
choses comme ça et on inflige des choses
abominables aux gamins qui arrive au
creps qui arrive à l'insep qui arrive
dans le pôle parce que on leur fait
croire que il faut être capable
d'endurer tout si on veut devenir un
champion et puis on éduque et on est
éduqué à ça en tant que sportif et on
est dans un état d'esprit où en fait
tout le monde nous dit qu'il faut être
capable de faire tous les sacrifices si
on veut devenir champion et ce discours
disant qu'il faut être capable de faire
tous les sacrifices baisse c'est ça
aussi qui facilite le fait que des
prédateurs s'en prennent à des sportifs
qui ont l'ambition de représenter leur
pays et de ramener une médaille pour la
france pour pour leurs parents qui se
sont sacrifiés également pour l'euro
derrière qu'envoûtant vous en temps on
se dit on n'a pas envie de laisser nos
enfants aller faire du sport de haut
niveau donc comment on fait comment on
fait il suffit d'être un peu plus
vigilant alors on parle beaucoup de ce
que sont les messages de prévention
qu'on peut adresser
a tout les atouts les sportifs oui il
faut être vigilant il faut avoir
connaissance de ce qui se fait de ce
qu'il se fait pas et il ya d d d
opération d'éducation qui vont dans ce
sens mais il faut également parler des
attitudes parentales qui pour certaines
je suis désolé de le dire c'est
difficile de ne pas culpabiliser les
parents mais parfois il y a des parents
qui sont négligents qui déposent leurs
gamins au sort et qui ne cherchent pas à
savoir ce qui se passe à sion il faut se
poser la question de quelle est la
relation que mon enfant avec
l'entraîneur avec les autres encadrants
du club et il faut que je donne la
possibilité à mon enfant de me raconter
ce qui se passe si au sein de la
structure familiale on peut pas en
parler comment voulez vous qu ensuite
lorsqu'un sportif ou une sportive est
victime comment voulez vous qu'elle en
parle ce n'est pas possible bien sûr
on